hey did you hear that tape of JD when he
first met Stephanie he he wanted her he
didn't know she was with you yeah I did
hear good one I got to play that really
I didn't hear this I mean you want to
hear something [__] crazy sure s has
a Blog party mhm Stephanie's there yeah
like oh this girl's kind of close to my
age or whatever oh yeah talking yeah wow
she's like from the same area as me like
we're like mhm wow I might have met
someone to act like talk to or whatever
right that you could be with next thing
I know Monday it was not a good thing to
go after her or think about her or
whatever because she was with Ronnie
Ronnie JD is it awkward for you to go to
the wedding is it painful cuz that
you're attracted to
Stephan no that uh that was a very
shortlived uh uh Crush you know what I
love about you JD yes you're like your
standards are so weird it's like hey
she's from oh Ohio I'm from Ohio this is
it this is they're not even living in
Ohio anymore what difference does that
make we were talking and it was someone
that you know was listen she was talking
back to me she was nice to me so of
course I liked her how about this I met
this girl she's from Earth and I'm from
Earth right sounds perfect and JD told
someone at work a couple of days later
that he had feelings for Stephanie and
then the guy said to JD don't go there
cuz she's Ronnie's girl
you imagine if JD had stolen Stephanie
from Ronnie oh my God all hell would
have broken loose are you gonna be that
guy at the wedding that stands up when
they say does anyone object and you're
going to start no no stop it is Elvis
gonna say that her her her her and
Ronnie are meant for each other so oh
yeah that's been determined yeah she and
Ronnie no her and Ronnie new language
Ronnie and her Ronnie and
she